[ __ ] a balance could provide an
update in the moment about Prince Harry
and Megan's future Prince Harry is
reportedly hoping to join his wife and
son in Canada after more meetings next
week but according to the British
tabloids there are still some major
stumbling blocks Jonathan Vigliotti is
in Vancouver where the couple might
establish roots Jonathan how do people
there feel about their potential new
neighbors Michelle good morning to you
in a very unofficial poll conducted by
myself most Canadians understand the
need for the couple to escape the media
though if it's any indication the
British tabloids and yes the mainstream
media are here following them in
Vancouver listen I spent about a month
with them in Australia traveling with
them on their royal tour and even back
then it was very clear they were
breaking royal tradition by not meeting
one-on-one with the traveling press at
that point very clear they were deciding
to take things their own way
while Buckingham Palace has yet to
finalize exit plans for two of its most
popular Royals their speculation Prince
Harry is sending his own message he
released this video on Instagram
Thursday of what could be his last royal
engagement set to a song that includes
the lyrics and like to leave the country
for a month of Sundays
[Music]
his expected destination Vancouver
Canada where his wife Megan Markel was
seen on Tuesday visiting two women's
charities Harry could join her within
weeks as a Canadian what did you think
about that Canada is part of the
Commonwealth a group of Nations once
under British rule where the queen is
still officially the head of state
symbolically granting power to the
acting government it's unclear what
royal status Harry and Megan would
retain if they start living in Canada
can they actually blend in here in
Canada I think the CAG Sean wade is with
the Royal Commonwealth Society in
British Columbia what kind of special
status will they have when they move
here well I think that didn't remains to
be seen
he'll be living here now whether he'll
be just a private permanent resident
whether he'll take on some duties I
don't know where Harry and Megan go
money is expected to follow destination
BC the official tourism bureau of
British Columbia estimates that when
Prince William and Kate Middleton
visited in 2016 the coverage was worth
more than one and a half million dollars
in free advertising for the Commonwealth
still locals are divided as to whether
or not the press will treat the couple
here in Canada any differently than they
were treated in the UK people here
should just leave them alone but they
can't like the media local radio
stations it's really unfortunate they
just can't let people live their lives
the way they want to live it and in a
recent national survey 40 percent of
Canadians said they were excited to have
the royal couple here ten percent said
they found it upsetting but Tony and
true laid-back Canadian fashion 50% of
people a said they really just don't
care thank you very much I love that so
Canadian I love the hockey jerseys on
the street yes for sure